there is a potential for uh the work of
the gchq and similar agencies to be
hampered in to some degree uh but the
other part of this is that a significant
portion of what they've been doing and
their connection with nsa has actually
been approved by the court so there are
so many factors that are related to this
where
from an operational standpoint i think
it will still be possible for the
intelligence agencies to do their job
but they might find it more difficult to
do it and might have a
less of a responsive time when it comes
to actually answering queries from uh
military or political leaders in this
case
in terms of dealing with this massive
data and uh
uh the illegal activities is the bulk
interception of
many thousands of people's innocent
people's data is that really necessary
my personal opinion is that it is not
necessary now i say that because i
believe that there are ways in which we
can go in and get very precise data on
people that we're interested in
the other part of this though is that
when you look at how
data is collected in this day and age
when you look at the i t infrastructure
and the way in which we communicate
nowadays there is an argument to be made
that you need to understand what the
cyber landscape is all about uh so you
need to understand what is normal within
that cyber landscape and then go after
the anomalies and to understand what is
normal sometimes you have to know uh
what the baseline is and that may
involve the collection of certain data
that
basically deals in the aggregate and not
in the details so in other words you
wouldn't collect the actual emails but
what you would collect is the data that
pertains to the so-called metadata
but
the best way to do this in my view is to
have a very pinpoint collection effort
that goes for very specific individuals
targets them and uh you understand you
would understand it based on other
intelligence indicators and that that
would be the ideal world